c'est l'heure du journal de l'Afrique
soyez les bienvenus sur France 24 à la
une ce soir l'Union européenne
préoccupée après la décision prise par
le chat de prolonger la transition de
deux ans mahadi Driss Déby maintenue à
la tête de l'État a également été
autorisé à briguer la présidence des
mesures adoptées dans le cadre d'un
dialogue boycotté par une grande partie
de l'opposition un de ces leaders succès
massera et notre invité ce soir
interview dans un instant
en Guinée les forces d'opposition ont
rejeté le dialogue tel qu'il est proposé
par la jante le colonel Mamadou
Doumbouya avait lancé le 19 septembre
dernier un cadre de dialogue inclusif
pour associer aux positions et société
civile aux affaires politiques pendant
la période de transition et puis à la
fin de ce journal nous parlerons
environnement alors que la précop prend
fin à Kinshasa en République
démocratique du Congo les experts
présents espèrent un respect des
engagements pris d'ici 2025 la situation
est déjà très préoccupante nous irons au
Kenya où les agriculteurs tentent de
cultiver un riz plus résistant reportage
à suivre
préoccupé c'est le terme utilisé par
l'Union européenne après la décision du
Tchad de prolonger de deux ans la
transition et de maintenir à la tête de
l'État le chef de la jinte au pouvoir
m'amatise débit il pourra même se porter
candidat la présidence il s'était
pourtant engagé à ne pas le faire des
mesures prises par des centaines de
délégués réunis dans le cadre d'un
dialogue de réconciliation nationale un
dialogue boycotté par une grande partie
de l'opposition dont fait par tes
parties succès massera leader des
transformateurs merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous ce soir alors première
question j'aimerais vous faire réagir
justement sur cette prolongation de de
cette période de transition comment vous
l'avez vous l'avez reçu cette
prolongation au-delà de la durée il y a
un certain nombre d'engagements 18 mois
sur lequel les gens se sont engagés la
modification de la charge sur lequel sur
laquelle les gens sont engagés
l'organisation des élections c'est tout
ça qui a fait un consensus au sein de
l'Union africaine au sein de la
communauté international c'est ce sur
quoi les militaires se sont engagés et
aujourd'hui ceux qui discutent dans
l'eau dans le palais ils savent bien que
ceux qui ont créé les conditions pour
que ce dialogue cette transition ait
lieu ne sont pas dans la salle que ça
soit nous de l'Intérieur qui avons
manifester organiser des marchés des
dizaines de semaines que ce soit les
politico armées qui ont lancé
l'offensive ces deux principaux acteurs
ne sont pas dans la salle donc les
décisions de la salle ne peut pas
engager l'ensemble des Tchadiens c'est
une décision d'une minorité des
Tchadiens et donc je crois que tout le
monde attend une clarification de tous
les acteurs y compris le Conseil
militaire de transition à travers son
président puisqu'il s'est engagé sur un
certain nombre de choses s'il veut
maintenant changer c'est à Lui
d'expliquer aux uns aux autres et les
partenaires au-delà des communiquer
d'indignation au-delà de dire préoccuper
j'ai pas noté le mot condamnation et
donc je crois que tout le monde est
appelé au rendez-vous de la
clarification aujourd'hui alors je
parlais de cette prolongation que est-ce
que vous vous considérez qu'elle est
légitime aujourd'hui est-ce que ce
dialogue national et légitime il s'est
conclu aujourd'hui
quel est le bilan de ce dialogue moi je
crois que quand on a des responsabilités
au sommet de l'État quand on s'engage on
les tient on a l'étadian assisté en vue
des officiers venez prendre la parole à
la télé et ce sont engagés sur 18 mois
et y compris à rendre le pouvoir aussi
vivre à travers des élections auxquelles
ils ne participerait pas si aujourd'hui
il change c'est une nouvelle donne aucun
des engagements pris n'a été respecté il
y en a pas un seul qui a été respecté
donc si on veut continuer la suite ce
sera sur des nouvelles bases les équipes
la méthode le rythme les organes la
manière de faire doivent changer puisque
si on n'a pas honoré ces engagements on
n'est pas en légitimité même de
continuer de la même manière en fait ce
dialogue nous nous avons pas nous n'y
avons pas pris la prépare et nous avons
voulu organiser en parallèle un dialogue
du peuple qui était plus populaire plus
diversifiée qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
plus de 1300 personnes en cumulées ont
été arrêtées plus de 8 personnes ont été
blessées dans les derniers événements
que vous avez assisté du premier au 9
septembre où on a même tiré sur notre
siège etc et lorsqu'on regarde la
question sécuritaire on a fait le
décompte macabre de avril 2021
aujourd'hui plus de 1000 chanens sont
tués entre les rebelles et les forces
armées les marcheurs 17 de nos marchés
ont été abattus mais aussi dans oui
localités différentes dont la dernière
en date magale mais on a vu plus de 1000
tchadiens qui sont tués pas par des
terroristes par des Tchadiens armés
contre d'autres tchadiens donc ça veut
dire qu'on doit tout recommencer pour
aller de l'avenir sur des nouvelles
bases parce qu'il faut discuter avec les
vrais acteurs pour continuer la suite
alors êtes-vous inquiète par rapport à
cette répression le ONG Human Right
Watch avait condamné l'usage de la force
notamment contre vos partisans et
membres de votre partie êtes-vous inqui
aujourd'hui il y a des morts il y a eu
des morts et les gens assistaient en
direct à une répression géolocalisée
live Twitter d'une certaine manière qui
me permettait l'expression et donc ceci
n'est pas acceptable et donc au-delà
inquiet c'est une aberration et c'est
inimaginable qu'au 21e siècle en soi
amené à Bayonnais donc ça devient une
sorte de monologue à main armée et ça
nous devons rompre avec cela donc ça
veut dire que ce qui s'est passé dans au
palais qui est en train d'être clôturé
d'ailleurs sans électricité soit dit en
passant parce qu'il y avait même pas de
lumière dans la salle donc c'est un
signe des temps il faut un peu de
lumière dans ce qui est en train d'être
fait là pour nous permettre d'aller de
l'avenir sous de nouvelles bases alors
vous avez parlé des engagements qui
n'ont pas été respectés notamment le
fait que ma matrice débit puisse briguer
un mandat présidentiel il s'était engagé
à ne pas le faire ne craignez-vous pas
l'instauration d'une dynastie comme
c'est le cas au Gabon ou même
au Togo avec la famille Yassine B au
pouvoir depuis des décennies moi je
crois à la démocratie je suis engagé
pour la démocratie les Tchadiens veulent
la démocratie cette abondance jeunesse
tchadienne d'Afrique centrale mais aussi
d'Afrique de manière globale regarder le
Sahel regarder l'énergie et l'espoir de
cette jeunesse qu'est-ce que nous
voulons nous voulons la démocratie pour
avoir quoi le choix nos dirigeants les
problèmes de notre pays le Tchad et de
nombreux pays c'est que les Tchadiens
les Africains n'ont pas choisi leur
dirigeants nous nous battons pour ça et
nous demandons à ce que tout ce qu'ils
veulent être les amis de notre peuple
clarifier leur position et c'est
maintenant ou jamais sinon nous allons
assister à ce que j'appelle les ruptures
définitives
[Musique]
probablement
qu'il n'y ait plus fermement des des
coups d'État que ce soit au Burkina Faso
récemment ou même en Guinée et la
position qui est prise est un peu plus
timide qu'est-ce que vous attendez de la
part de la communauté internationale que
ce que vous attendez de cette communauté
internationale et de la France en
particulier je dis au peuple africains
regarder observé comme des sentinelles
avec la ferme en conviction que
finalement votre destin entre vos mains
en tout cas cette jeunesse africaine
c'est elle que je m'adresse mais nous
disons nous attendons rien de
particulier sauf à ce que les uns et les
autres tiennent leur engagement et se
rangent du côté des peuples d'une
certaine manière tout le monde a entendu
je crois que nous l'avions dit à
l'époque que la crédibilité de l'Union
africaine la crédibilité des partenaires
comme la France qui se sont engagés de
manière publique en disant qu'il ne
soutiendront jamais un plan de
succession dynastie nous nous souhaitons
pas la dynastie c'est pas une question
de patronyme ou de non nous souhaitons
la démocratie peu importe qui doit aller
sur le terrain ça doit être la
démocratie pour que les Tchadiens et les
Africains choisissent dans les urnes
leur dirigeants c'est à long de cela que
nous jaugerons si nous avons des vrais
amis ou pas et mon intime conviction
c'était c'est la dernière chance la
dernière chance qui souffre à ses
partenaires là de pouvoir être clair
parce que en fait ils sortent des cœurs
de cette nouvelle génération dont nous
faisons partie qui sont 70 % 80 % de la
population africaine ils sortiront
définitivement ils n'auront plus autres
possibilités pour l'avenir donc ça se
joue maintenant les heures les jours les
semaines qui qui suivent seront des
jours décisifs je dirais pour l'avenir
pour les 50 prochaines années merci
beaucoup succès massera d'être venu
répondre à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes opposant tchadien leader du
mouvement des transformateurs merci
beaucoup merci à vous et on parle du
dialogue en Guinée cette fois les forces
d'opposition ont rejetées telles qu'il
est proposée par la jante une jante
accusée d'exercices autoritaires du
pouvoir le colonel mamadouia a mis en
place le 19 septembre dernier un cadre
de dialogue inclusif pour associer le
plus grand nombre aux affaires
politiques pendant la période de
transition Malik Diakité notre
correspondant à Conakry
parmi les formations politiques qui
refusent catégoriquement ce dialogue
proposé par les autorités le RPG
arc-en-ciel le parti du président de
chez Alpha Condé ou encore Lana de une
coalition politique qui soutient celui
d'Alan Diallo leader de l'opposition les
militaires proposant un dialogue
inter-guinéant chapeauté par le Premier
ministre avec des médiateurs nationaux
mais alléluia politique eux exigeons un
cadre de dialogue où ils pourront
discuter directement avec les militaires
au pouvoir sous la médiation de la
CEDEAO nous demandons un cadre de
dialogue sincère ou le CNRB est en face
de la classe politique avec comme
facilitateur la CEDEAO
et là on sait où se trouve le problème
ce n'est pas à eux de proposer les TDR
ce n'est pas à eux de proposer des
personnes les deux parties s'asseyent
ils discutent sur le TDR il y a pas de
sincérité dans ce qu'il propose comme
cadre de dialogue il n'y a pas de
sincérité pour le président du Conseil
National de la Transition ce dialogue
devra permettre au guinéant de se mettre
ensemble le Président de la Transition a
instruit le Premier ministre de
rencontrer tous les acteurs alors si ces
acteurs refusent pour une raison pour
une haute de venir au dialogue ce n'est
plus le gouvernement c'est ces acteurs
qui ne veulent pas en ce moment
dialoguer et l'opinion nationale
internationale sera pris en témoin dans
ce sens là mais je ne pense pas que vu
l'importance de cette transition qu'un
acteur puisse accepter d'être la marge
de ce processus parce que l'avenir du
pays dépend de notre capacité à nous
mettre ensemble pour faire ce travail on
dîner le principal point d'achoppement
entre les différentes parties restent
encore la durée de la
au pouvoir pendant trois ans une durée
rejetée par la classe politique mais
aussi par la Cedeao Communauté
économique des États de l'Afrique de
l'Ouest
au Burkina Faso le bilan de l'attaque de
gaskinde dans le nord du pays à de
nouveau été revus à la hausse il fait
état de 37 morts 27 soldats et 10 civils
selon l'état-major de l'armée burkinabè
au Rwanda les trois journalistes détenus
depuis quatre ans et poursuivi notamment
pour avoir diffusé de fausses
informations ont été acquittées les
associations de défense des droits de
l'homme ont qualifié la procédure de
simulacre la correspondance à Kigali de
Clément di Roma
l'annonce du verdict n'aura duré que
quelques minutes mais les trois
journalistes arrêtés en 2018 seront
restés 4 ans en détention provisoire
elles étaient à la tête d'une chaîne
Youtube rwandaise d'actualité avec plus
de 200 000 abonnés ils étaient accusés
entre autres d'avoir diffusé de faux
informations en 2018 alors le procureur
demandez-vous 22 ans d'emprisonnement
pour les trois accusés une requête qui
était jugée choquante pour le Comité
pour la protection des journalistes une
ONG internationale au final la Haute
cour de kigalit les a quitté aujourd'hui
jugeant que les profs de l'accusation
étaient et bien insuffisantes alors
c'est en soulagement évidemment pour les
accusés leurs familles et le monde de la
presse ici ils n'ont publié que la
vérité ce sont les mots de l'avocat de
la défense qui espèrent que cette
conclusion restera dans les esprits ici
selon l'OMG Human Right Watch depuis
2018 plus d'une dizaine de blogueurs de
journalistes et de commentateurs sur
Youtube ont été détenus arrêtés ou
poursuivi en justice en 2021 la même
cour a condamné deux youtubeurs à
respectivement 15 et 7 ans de prison
il réclamait l'accès à ses documents
confidentiels depuis très longtemps
c'est un soulagement pour les
descendants de Patrice Lumumba la
justice belge vient de décider de verser
au dossier les comptes rendus d'une
commission d'enquête parlementaire qui
s'est tenue il y a plus de 20 ans sur
l'assassinat du Premier ministre
congolais de quoi peut-être faire
avancer cette instruction ouverte depuis
2011 après une plainte de la famille
Lumumba demandant à ce que la lumière
soit faite sur la mort de leurs proches
il y a plus de 60 ans avec la complicité
de l'ancien colonisateur la Belgique je
vous propose d'écouter l'avocat de la
famille Lumumba qui se réjouit de cette
décision elle répondait aux questions de
notre correspondante à Bruxelles Alix le
bourde
très important parce que finalement ce
que ce qu'on recherche ce que la famille
recherche c'est la vérité et on se bat
pour le droit à la vérité qu'à un moment
donné on connaît tous les éléments qui
ont mené à cette assassinat horrible et
on espère que dans ces informations
confidentielles on aura des informations
complémentaires qui permettront de
compléter le dossier
le congrès de la pré cop27 à Kinshasa en
République démocratique du Congo touche
à sa fin plus de
la région de muéa produit 80% du riz du
Kenya
en 2021 le manque de pluie a eu un
impact dévastateur les cultures ont
donné 40 % de céréales en moins mais à
caillou
les trois dernières années nous n'avons
pas eu de bonnes pluies le rendements
ont été très faibles en raison du manque
d'eau le riz est très dépendant de l'eau
le Kenya connaît en ce moment sa plus
forte sécheresse des cars en dernière
année
pour contrer les effets de ces
phénomènes météorologiques de plus en
plus fréquents le gouvernement a
introduit une nouvelle variété de riz
développés pour le climat du pays
de beaucoup d'eau à l'endroit où je me
trouve en ce moment il n'y avait pas
d'eau au cours des dernières semaines et
il a quand même poussé
pourtant seul 20% des agriculteurs
de en majorité il continue de planter
celles plus dépendantes à l'eau pour les
aider le gouvernement à inaugurer
mi-août un nouveau système de barrage et
de canaux mais ce n'est pas suffisant
pour accroître la production alors des
organisations encouragent les
agriculteurs à adopter les nouvelles
semences
ces technologies qui permettent
d'obtenir un meilleur rendement avec la
même quantité d'eau et la même surface
de terre vont nous aider à combler
l'écart entre nos importations et la
demande de riz que nous avons
d'ici 2030 le Kenya prévoit de produire
assez pour satisfaire sa consommation le
doublement du rendement des nouvelles
variétés devraient permettre de faire
face aux changements climatique et aider
à alimenter la population
cette année dans le pays 3,5 millions de
personnes souffrent d'un manque de
nourriture dû à la sécheresse
voilà c'est la fin de journal de
l'Afrique restez avec nous dans quelques
instants la suite de Paris direct
[Musique]
entre 1970 et 1980 des citoyens japonais
disparaissent mystérieusement on le
découvrira par la suite avec
stupéfaction ce programme de kidnapping
a été orchestré par la Corée du Nord
c'était la guerre froide et la mère du
Japon était le théâtre de tension
l'aiguille au quota aurait été enlevée à
cette intersection
en 2002 Kim Jong Hill reconnaît très
enlèvement mais combien de personnes en
réalité ont-elles été enlevées et dans
combien de pays alors que les États-Unis
se portent solidaires des victimes la
Corée du Nord a rompu le dialogue et de
nombreuses zones d'ombre plein de temps
encore sur ce dossier d'espionnage
international
billet retour Annie Gata avoir sur
France 24 et France 24 com
le 93 c'est son terrain de jeu on y va
Sarah Ouattara à la tête d'une agence
d'événementiel compte bien tirer parti
de l'arrivée de grandes entreprises dans
son département sa stratégie mettre en
avant les talons locaux accrochez-vous
bien un cercle vertueux ou le 93 créer
l'événement c'est dans pas de quartier
on est surtout à l'affût des initiatives
sur le territoire et à chaque fois on
garde le sourire
pas de quartier à voir sur France 24 et
France 24 com